[Music]
today's question comes from bella in
california
i have a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in school loans my fiance has no
debt and has more than that amount in
savings for a house down payment we've
been together for five years i believe
my loans are setting us back on marriage
and buying a home together
he prioritizes his quote financial
planning more than the progress of our
relationship
i'm working my butt off to pay these
loans while he has the cash to help me
and ultimately us he insists on holding
on to the down payment money instead of
helping me he says he wants to marry me
but i feel that his timeline is not very
timely i need perspective on whether i
am right in all of this
george you've been married sooner than
me what are your thoughts on this well i
feel like this is less of a financial
question and more of a relationship
question i don't like this idea of he's
prioritizing financial planning over our
relationship and i want to know if i'm
right or and if he's wrong these are
just backwards ways of thinking about
this relationship and uh i think i think
both of them are wrong in in some ways
uh i think
they need to have a we mentality if
they're about to get married and these
loans are about to become his loans and
their loans instead of well that's her
thing
and i've got my money here that i've
worked so hard for now she's screwing
all this up
that attitude is going to hurt them
in marriage
bell yeah this this is there's a big
giant flashing red sign
saying stop danger ahead
and
i know you love this guy and i'm
confident that he loves you
but you all are living parallel lives
and parallel tracks and you are trying
to combine lives combined futures you
are hitching your wagon to this guy and
him to you
but you're trying to do it halfway
and so before anybody takes any more
steps you only need to get in with a
premarital counselor
today tomorrow asap
this is a recipe for
a disaster an absolute disaster
um you're not on the same page
financially you're not on the same page
relationally you're not on the same page
for supporting one another
earlier in one of the breaks i got a
question on on social media somebody
asked me um like some
secret tips of marriage i asked george
and um
he said out serve each other that's
exactly right
and this one is out ernie y'all are
trying to out earn each other try to out
compete each other out work your butts
off for each other and this is just the
backwards way into a marriage backwards
way
by the way this question right here i
need perspective on whether i am right
in all of this not what to do but
whether i'm right let me be super clear
if you have an argument with your spouse
or your fiance and one of you wins you
both lose
arguments in marriage are not to be won
or lost they're
you're not at war in competition with
your spouse or with your fiance you're
both the problem is the problem the
challenge is the problem you're trying
to solve something together not win
against one another and if you find
yourself in competition i want to know
if i'm right or i think he's wrong
you are on dangerous ground man john i
can count on zero fingers how many times
i have won an argument with my wife and
it brought us closer together
zero no zero never so here's my thing if
i'm in their shoes and they they can get
on the same page
what i don't want is for him to be
resentful because he had all this money
and i paid off the loans instantly as
soon as they got married and now he's
resentful because like all this i worked
so hard for this and she took it all
away
it's going to create a lot of resentment
now that's the right thing to do
financially because now you are one and
her debt is your debt
but i don't want this to create
resentment and i feel that like that's
what's going to happen if he does this
yeah and if it doesn't it's going to
create resentment on her part because
she's stuck paying her loans and he's
going to go i'm not paying your loans
i'll get us the house because that's my
thing but i'm not touching your debt and
then she lives in quote unquote his
house as his wife as the the
mother of the children in that home
they're all living in his house yep
because you've got this debt you're
working on it's a dangerous situation
this is not heading down a good road
already so they need to get on the same
page or rather otherwise this is not
going to work regardless of the finances